(electronic music)
- [Owen] Chester, your gazebo
is really coming along.
- [Chester] Thanks, Owen.
- It looks great.
- Tell you what, there's
no place I'd rather be.
- Agreed.
(yelling)
(symphonic music)
(car horn)
- Oh, my.
- Whoa.
- I've seen some stuff,
I've built some stuff
but I've never seen or
built anything like this.
- [Gangster] Give me all that money.
- Yes, I
We will totally cooperate
What is all of this stuff, what is this?
Whoa, whoa, oh I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- Is he okay?
- Uh-Oh. (explosions)
- Hi we're new in town
Is this your friend?
Yeah, no, let's go!
Sir, we need to borrow your car.
Oh my god, I'm crushing his head
on the car.
- Why would you do that?
- I donno my body went on autopilot.
- Just get in the car, I'll drive.
(squealing tires)
- Whoa! This thing's quick.
- Look out, look out, look out!
Ahh!
- Whoa, lady! I'm sorry.
(guns firing)
- I am covered in guns right now.
- Do it. Do it.
- Okay. Hey are you guys still chasing us?
Spray and pray, cocksuckers! (guns firing)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah!
I'm going on the sidewalk.
Oh my god, I love this,
fuckin' love this. Crazy!
- I'm so hard right now.
Oh am I gettin' there.
(tires squealing)
- Hey grandma! What's on special?
- [Grandma] Suck your nuts,
mister. Five dollars a ball.
- We'll take four balls please.
- Yes.
- You boys wanna double up my asshole?
- She just keeps offering us things.
- Why don't you fuck
the grey outta my pussy?
- Yes, yes we'd like to
have sex with you just...
(tires squealing)
- Ohhh.
- Get out. Here's a gold,
thanks for your time.
- Go back to whatever
stoop you crawled out of.
- Stink in here.
- That was so rude, why
did we act that way?
- That was really mean I
don't know what came over me.
- Let's go back and apologize.
- Oh! Ahh! (laughing)
- Oh my god that woman took my virginity
and the you hit her with our car.
- All of our money came out of her body.
I'm gonna go pick it up.
(arcade token bell)
- Look what else she had.
- Whaaaat?
(folksy guitar music)
- You know it's fucked up man.
- What? What, what?
- I feel like I've lived so much, today,
and I'm like what have I
been doing my whole life?
- Shit, dude. You and me both.
- What do you wanna do today?
Let's get some wood and build a gazebo.
Why? I wanna fuck an old
woman and run her over.
- You did jack it off.
You see what I see?
- Do it, do it, do it.
(yelling laughter)
(crashing)
(techno music)
- Owen, are you in here?
Ah! Owen are you alright?
Alright, have fun.
(groaning)
(techno music)
(electronic music)